not only animals but also plans are an
inspiration for scientists welcome to
the show the cacti collection and it's
collector and creator professor coast of
nine whose and bionics expert now what
can you actually learn from a cactus
besides that it's prickly so the
different things you can learn actually
what we did is we investigated larger
one than this calamba cacti which have
inner core a wood cylinder like this so
you strip the outside off right so the
outer water storage tissue is gone and
the wood cylinder remains and what
interests us is if you look at a regular
tree the site launches they increase the
diameter towards a stem to cope with the
loads if you look at a columnar cacti
the side branches have the smallest
diameter exactly at the bar and you
would expect them to easily break off on
loads actually they don't and that's
what's the surprising thing was despite
the fact that it's very lightweight not
fair if an engineer actually constructed
like that you'd probably say a pretty
bad job right sqd would probably fail in
its exim yeah if God if he constructs
the junk like that so the question we
asked was why does a cocktail did the
cacti do it like this and what's a
special construction of it and how can
we learn something for engineering
formula and what did you find out what's
so special about the cactus the special
is the the cause of the wood fibers how
the branch is connected to the stem and
this fiber arrangement this is what we
studied and that we try to copy in a
lightweight carbon fiber structure like
this so this has been voided on a big
machine with a robot arm and in one
complicated process to make a branched
lightweight carbon fiber composite
material it actually looks pretty simple
how long did it take you to roll this is
actually protest of several years of
interacting between biology and
engineering to
to transfer the process and the
principle of the bunch of the characters
into a carbon-fiber composite area now
nature is only working through trial and
error how come nature and evolution is
still more creative than engineers I
won't put it like this but nature often
has because of limitations of the of the
individual species the need to look for
unusual should solution for problems
especially under extreme conditions like
a cactus and this is what we are looking
for and how we think that for the future
we might find quite interesting
adaptations which also relevant for
engineering yeah about 20 years ago
maybe researchers were quite euphoric
about bionics but then besides the water
repellent surfaces nothing really came
out right oh no I would put it put it
like that one of the most spectacular
and probably most successful stores is
very cool it had it's a bionic
development and it's used everywhere in
the world also optimization processes
used to shape and structures like that
are quite common every car has a bionic
lee optimized structure in it nobody
speaks about it and what's the next step
to come what's the most important field
in bionics I think the most important
thing will be molecular bionics how can
we mimic the process of building
together small molecules to increasingly
complex structures how nature does it
and I think that's the future thanks a
lot for the talk because I knows things
you